hello folks
and welcome to rational science
what do we do in this channel well we do
science
or we try to do science um
specifically physics now uh
why is it called rational well because
we're a little different than
what everybody else does out there see
you see everybody else out there follows
not the scientific method they follow
the
mathematical method and the mathematical
method has
led to what we have today irrational
explanations
for just about every invisible
intangible phenomenon
you know like gravity uh magnetism
they can't see it they can't explain it
not in a rational way not the mechanism
okay that's the issue the causes
okay so uh here's a quick rundown
of how we see science how we see physics
we have a material interpretation of
physics
unlike everybody else who uses moves
concepts around
or uh you know abstractions or
they move particles particles which
aren't
particles that's the issue
the particles these people use are
really amounts
that don't have a specific location but
they're talking about probabilities
okay so it's all abstractions we use
objects we use
things and for that you had to start
with the golden principle of physics
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an
object okay i mean imagine there was
nothing in the universe no objects no
somethings no things no
entities whatever word you want to use
in there
body substance okay
if you have no body no thing in front of
you
what's happening what are you observing
what experiment can you run assuming you
know you want to do experiments
what can you measure there's nothing
in front of you you need a something
to do physics physics is founded on some
things on things
on objects as we call them so one of the
first things we have to do is define the
word object
okay and so that's what we do here it is
an object is that which has shape
and if the object wants to exist it has
to have
in addition it has to have location
there has to be distance between that
object and my chest my ear my nose
okay so if god wants to exist he's got
to have location
meaning he's got to have distance with
respect to every object in the universe
and before that he's got to be an object
so we have to define what an object is
the object is that which has shape and
what is existence well it's
object plus location you have to have
location
in order to exist for the purposes of
physics
again we reject um
ordinary speech which is what people
usually bring into science
um what do we propose we propose
not only definitions that we can use
consistently rationally
scientifically right we propose the rope
hypothesis
light is neither a
series of particles you know flow of
particles
or a transverse wave which is what they
use today
so it's none of these two
use any of those two you're going to end
up with irrational
explanations why
why are these two irrational
first of all because they're one way
second
you know their one-way mechanism they
only travel one way and light is a
two-way mechanism
and the other issue here is that the
wave at least at the top
is a concept there is no physical
standalone object called
a wave wave is a verb
wave is something that happens
not something and on the bottom you see
the particles but
you know how do you get those particles
to wave up and down that's the issue
because
we know or have the experience or have
certified or
or the uh the issue is out there that
light is some kind of wave phenomena in
other words
light behaves as waves
and you can't do that with particles if
you move them up and down you got to
tell the crowd why the particle is
moving up
why the particle is moving down okay so
uh again they end up with irrational
explanations
uh because they insist on this particle
hypothesis the so-called
photon what is a photon a discrete
particle
and is it the classical particle no they
say well it's a
quantum particle and a quantum particle
means it's a magical particle that's
what they mean by that
they cannot explain anything with
real you know dust particles like you
say
what is a particle oil you think of a
speck of dust
that's not what quantum means by
particle particle means amount
means not a thing but a concept a
mathematical concept
that has location no that can be
uh put into a probability scheme
that's that's what we have today so we
have mathematics and no
physical interpretations for mechanisms
invisible mechanisms specifically
uh we also propose that humans are in
their last leg we're about to become
extinct as humans we are the last humans
on earth nothing to celebrate not a very
popular theory
obviously and um what do we propose for
that we
propose that the mechanism of a mass
extinction which is what's going to
happen to man
is the overturning of the ecological
pyramid
that comes at the heels of uh plants
overturning okay so the plants which is
the primary production
uh they overturned their population
pyramid they lose their genetic
diversity
uh and it's an economic collapse uh what
we have done is we kind of accelerated
the process by domesticating plants
and what we do is we grow plants
ourselves
we are the ones who produce the food on
the planet why do we do so we do
do we do it to uh because we love uh
humans uh because we do it for the
health
of our fellow man no we do it because
of money we do it because of profits
that's the only reason
all these major corporations produce
food and the day that our economy
collapses
well that's the end of food and the
argument
is that our economy our global economy
is
about to collapse it's not as far as i'm
concerned it's not
too far away okay it's uh coming to a
theater near you
very soon okay so uh
what are the differences between what we
have today in physics and what we
propose
well here it is a summary last 10 000
years everybody has proposed discrete
particles
and of course they end up with
irrational explanations
what do we propose instead we propose
that all
atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected
that is physically interconnected
what interconnects them uh what we call
the electromagnetic rope
essentially it's a pair of twine threads
and that pair of uh twine threads
um comes from this notion that there is
only a single
closed loop thread in all of space
that's all there is
and this single thread is what twines
around itself
and eventually uh produces all the
matter
uh that exists out there and it also
produces the
interconnecting ropes which you see here
at the bottom left
the atoms are doing their quantum jump
they're connected to each other through
this
physical rope and by doing the quantum
jump they torque the rope
signal goes in both directions
simultaneously and opposite directions
and that's why you can see me and i can
see you simultaneously
every atom in your eye is connected to
every atom in my
eye and what we have is torsions of that
rope
and those are the ones that give us that
little bump
uh to our atom which later on transmits
it through all
you know to the uh seeing mechanism that
you have in your
head right so that is in a nutshell
uh what we're proposing and um
let me get back in here
okay that is the uh the mechanism
or the general picture uh what can we
explain with this
well here you have a little uh
quick chart okay it tells you all the
invisible
intangible stuff uh phenomenal we can
explain out there
we can explain light because it's a
torsion not a
not a transverse wave going one way but
a torsion that goes both ways
and that goes along a physical mediator
which is the
rope what we call the electromagnetic
rope it's made out of those two threads
those threads also make up the atom one
thread goes through the center of the
atom the other one
curves around and it encapsulates what
we call the proton star
okay so what you see there is the proton
stars every rope in the universe
converges upon our atom and forms
our little atom uh we can also explain
electricity it's the um
merge shells of all these atoms really
the molecules
they're all aligned they spin in the
same direction
and by doing so they also
swing around themselves the threads
which are going to cause
what we call magnetism and as you would
expect it goes at 90 degrees
to the electricity
and there you can see the quick
mechanism when the
threads hit each other they push each
other away and you have
uh repulsion and the magnets on the
bottom right and when you turn the
magnet around
uh you see what you see there what you
see is that
when they go uh in the same direction uh
they pull on each other
okay one one group of threads comes down
the other one comes up
and they're pulling on each other okay
so that's
in general very quickly the summary
for uh how we explain these phenomena we
explain it with physical objects not
with
abstract concepts such as energy and
force and mass charge
field that time that
mathematical physics uses as
so-called explanations okay
and uh we can also explain gravity
something at least
uh quantum cannot explain and general
relativity
explains with the most ridiculous thing
that you can imagine which is
warped time how do you work time when
it's a concept
and they say well see that's just the
mathematical description
yeah but we have to explain why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
these people are saying there's a wall
of wartime
and the earth is rolling around this
wall of warp time
caused by the weight of the sun right
causes this depression in space
time and so time is warped and it's
time which is preventing the earth from
flying out of the solar system
so that is the physical interpretation
that general
relativity gives and it's a totally
irrational nonsense poppycock
so realistic not even so you cannot even
imagine
such a garbage and so uh
no it has no place in science what
general relativity proposes that's
mathematical gibberish we need a
physical interpretation for why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
okay so what is it that we have to
explain well here we have berkeley
professor if you want authority here you
have it berkeley professor
richard miller he tells you what we have
to explain this is what we have to
explain we have to explain
for example if you have the earth
there's this big mass here
that's that big circle there with a big
m in it and you have you with your
little mass here and that's you on top
of the earth right
every atom on earth is pulling on every
atom of you
you're also pulling on it the amazing
thing about gravity is that it goes
right through
things so we have to explain
pull we have to explain how it is that
every atom on earth
is pulling on every atom of
you the only way we can explain that if
they're connected
physically connected otherwise uh you're
doing black magic you're putting spirits
in that same
space okay that's the issue and so uh
here we explain it very quickly with a
quick picture that synthesizes it uh all
atoms are in the universe are
interconnected
the closer two objects are to each other
the more the ropes fan out
that's the bottom right there the
cylinder very close to the cube
and then when they're very far apart
which you see on the upper right
then the ropes form a single coaxial and
gravity
is weak so the closer you get the close
the more the
ropes fan out and that explains newton's
equation
which is not an equation of force it's
an exp
equation of tension of weight
weight is a tension at different
locations
weight is a static concept okay
and um so here you get an idea what
weight really is what that so-called
force meaning tension
is at different locations if the
astronaut weighs only 25 pounds it's
because he's very far away
as you get closer the ropes fan out you
can see the angles of the ropes changing
as we go from
25 50 75 and 200 pounds
and that's why you are accelerated
towards the earth because the ropes are
fanning out
every atom in your body connected to
every atom on earth
and what's happening each one is is not
pulling but i'm going to use the word
pull
they are at different angles as you
approach the earth
that is the acceleration of gravity okay
again i try to emphasize that there is
no pull
what you have is tension for every
single rope
at different locations and at the next
location
closer to in this case astronaut to the
earth
now you have more ropes which were
before on the same axis now they're on
different axis
that's what it is okay i hope you
understand that otherwise you can review
the
pictures you can also uh look at the
book free book downloadable book that is
in the description and you'll get
the rope hypothesis and you'll get a
better information
this is the dynamic version here that's
what's happening to the astronaut
the ropes are fanning out okay as he
falls to earth
okay and that applies to anything a
spoon falling to the floor has the same
effect
uh the as it falls closer to the center
of the earth the ropes fan out
okay so that's what we propose in a
nutshell
okay that's what this channel is
primarily about
and
what are the objections we have against
the establishment well
here's one of them just give you an
example here's electricity according to
the establishment
they think that electron beads electrons
you know
they flow from atom to atom what they've
done is they've gotten rid of the atom
as well and now they just have the flow
of beads
they do electricity just with beads okay
and so you say well what's wrong with
that well what's wrong is this
uh they cannot explain this
why uh why the electron stays
faithful to the atom before it starts
flowing
from atom to atom what keeps that
electron
bound to the nucleus that's the question
one other question the other one i mean
you got all kinds of questions
right in that picture and that is that
you know the uh
proton is is supposedly a sphere but
it's made of three spheres three
quarks now i challenge anyone on planet
earth to
make a sphere just taking three tennis
balls
see if you can produce a sphere so those
are some of the
issues the issue is there you cannot
explain especially
why that electron stays faithful to
the proton to that uh nucleus
and and to summarize all you have to do
is explain
what the white stuff inside those
circles are
we need to know what that white stuff is
what physical entity
occupies that space if you can't explain
that you don't have a model and you
can't even start your presentation
and that's where mathematical physics is
today
okay okay
um
last couple um lectures i talked about
two things the first one was uh
extinction and the second one was
existence
and uh we have a fellow who has in court
who
researches or looks at or is interested
in these subjects as well
he's incorporated information into the
picture
okay so here is let's present them
this follows his name is doug vogt
if i can get him up here okay
that's the gentleman here he wrote a
couple books
multi-dimensional reality
and the other one god's day of judgment
he's got some other books as well uh
these i guess
are his most prominent books and i've
underlined the word dimension and word
god
you see where this fellow might be
coming from
okay word dimension i'm a little worried
about because when they say
multi-dimension meaning many dimensions
you know there's only three dimensions
in physics
now in religion you can have
multi-dimensions uh you have the
religion of string theory they have up
to 26 dimensions some of them came up
with
today i think they settled around 10 or
11 you know depending on what group you
talk to
okay and so yeah i doubt that this
fellow here
uh doug vote he knows what a dimension
is he's probably using the dimensions of
mathematics
okay we've covered that in the past
here's a summary again
we got the dimensions coordinates and
vectors of physics
and there's only three of each and why
is there only three of each well you can
only have
uh 390 degree directions
okay you can have length width and
height and each one is 90 degrees to
another
there's no way you can imagine a fourth
perpendicular
direction to those three directions and
so what's
what happened is they say well it's
unimaginable and no kid
you cannot imagine but the real reason
is that mathematical physics doesn't
deal with dimensions coordinates or
vectors at all
they they use number lines and they call
those number lines dimensions
and so this is where the problem is they
use the language of physics and they
apply it to math and people think
they're talking
physics that's where the problem starts
and this fellow doug
vote apparently is in the same boat okay
he's
talking about multi-dimensional that's
already scary because it means he's
going to be using
the notion of mathematics okay
and the other problem is he introduces
god
and that is scary
that is uh eye-opening eye rolling
okay rolling your eyes
the mess he says uh this is his
uh general picture okay what he's gonna
say he says that by the year 2046
we might have extinction on our hands
because of what he says in these books
okay and i'm going to go over that in a
minute but here
here's kind of like the summary of or or
his goal or where he's headed
with all this it says the mass
extinctions and the creation of new
species and that it occurs during the
geomagnetic reversal
okay that's the subject matter that he
likes to cover
it is not just one disaster okay he's
talking about
what catastrophic accidents right
and this one's gonna have to do with the
uh
not a supernova he says the sun doesn't
supernova
it kind of mini or micros novas meaning
it it burps so to speak okay
and that causes fa havoc on earth every
12 thousand or so years
and the next one's due in 2 20 46
okay according to his calculations so
we're going to find out where it gets
this
these ideas these numbers etc okay it
says uh one disaster that occurs
at that time but a series of events each
one contributing
to the mass destruction catastrophic
accident mass destruction
you know uh stuff for hollywood right
it's gotta be
something that blows you away right that
occurred in the past
okay so his uh mass destruction
catastrophic
accident that's what causes extinction
that's essentially his argument okay
he's just got a different one it's not
asteroid it's not
gonna be um volcanoes or anything like
that
it's gonna be a nova or
a mini nova okay micro nova the nova
is is bad enough but what the oceans do
is equally destructive
okay so we're gonna have floods i guess
right the purpose of the
these videos is to forewarn people
of the disaster so people can force
government to make
preparations to save some of the people
you cannot do this on your own
so he's going to say that in the year
2046 apparently
right there's gonna be this nova this
mini nova or whatever
and i guess we're gonna have to run
around the planet so they're always on
the opposite side
of where the sun is hitting the earth so
we're all gonna have to move i guess to
the other side of the planet and roll
around with a planet as it spins
so we're going to spin around so that we
always stay in the same place
we go in the opposite direction of the
earth the earth goes this way
and we go that way right so we always
end up in the same place and the sun can
bombard our oceans or whatever from one
side i guess it's something like that
that he
plans to survive somehow like that or
maybe protect ourselves of
umbrellas of some kind i don't know you
know i didn't research that because
you will see it was not worth
my time we've got enough of what we got
on hand here today
okay so uh
mr um vogue has created a foundation
he calls it the thigh hold foundation
i'd rather
refer to it as the die hard foundation
because
he's a die-hard quantum mechanic a
die-hard
relativist a die-hard
string theories he's a diehard
mathematical physicist in other words
he's
bought into mathematical physics and
that's what he uses
as his foundation for his theory okay
so he created this die hold foundation
in 1987.
and its purpose is to accomplish four
major goals
the first one is to gather information
he wants to fund geological
expeditions in in order to
gather information on the past climate
and biomass
of selected regions of the earth the
period of interest is from 10 000
before the present to 120 000 before the
present
in other words he's going to look at
this um
period okay uh essentially the upper
paleolithic
uh you know when uh he thinks that
maybe there was some climate change
going on and that
maybe caused the extinction of some
species
and it was triggered in turn by this
thing
that he calls the nova okay we believe
we can determine what side of the earth
will be
facing the sun when it novas during the
next
geomagnetic reversal polar reversal okay
second reason is to research
gravitational anomalies found in the us
and the world as defined by whom by
douglas vogt okay
research will include testing and data
collection
testing and data collection that sounds
like mathematics
mathematical um
method the mathematical method not the
scientific method
we don't do tests we don't do data
collection why because
all those the only purpose is that is to
collect evidence
what is the purpose of evidence to
persuade and convince people
to prove a theory in science we don't do
any of that
in science we just explain a mechanism
so that people
understand and this fellow is again he's
in the
mathematical world because all he wants
to do is test collect data
why what for to persuade you
that's his intention we believe this
these uh gravitational anomalies are the
result of very highly
advanced technology by previous
civilization
oh my god we have uh
these people who believe that in the
past the
the our ancestors had more information
than
than we did had more knowledge and we
lost that knowledge somehow over time
maybe the klingons came over visited us
gave all this information to them and
then they squandered it away or
time you raised their who knows what
okay
so a lot of these people you see that in
the electric universe as well you know
they talk about
all these uh you know
aliens not not necessarily aliens but
the fact that our ancestors knew a lot
more than we do
okay the third reason is to fund
research covering the causes of past
ice ages again causes he doesn't need to
do any research or anything like that
all he's got to do is explain the
mechanism
then we'll understand the causes i say
just geomagnetic reversals mass
extinctions again he thinks a mass
extinction is catastrophic
uh caused by catastrophic agents mother
nature
throws uh you know asteroids or does
supernovas or maybe volcanic activity
that's how they visualize this stuff
another phenomenon related to the polar
reversals
okay the objective of the research is to
find a causal relationship between
geological cycles and
astronomical cycles within an
informational
theory of existence such as
the theory of multi-dimensional reality
what the hell is this theory about well
here it is you get a little uh
breakdown here a little synthesis what
he's talking about he says
the theory of multi-dimensional reality
is the world's first purely information
theory of existence of course he never
defined the word exist so we don't know
what he's talking about when he says
existence
you won't find it anywhere he just takes
the notion of ordinary speech
which all we have are synonyms we don't
have a definition
scientific definition so we don't know
what he's going to talk about but
it says he says it states that matter is
not the dominant thing in our universe
okay but rather information creates our
matter world
so matter comes from a concept turns out
that
concepts are all invented by man mother
nature
god the devil whoever you worship up
out there they don't understand what
this uh
thingy you call information this thingy
we call
concepts you know they don't understand
that all they can see is the material
stuff
again you can't do physics without
objects but this file says that all
these objects came from
a concept called information and all
concepts came from man
so it turns out the moon which was here
before us
was created by man because we created
out of our imagination
but maybe it wasn't man maybe it was
some someone else
so let's find out let's find out maybe
there's someone else who who did all
this
the theory is able to explain the most
difficult phenomena using the same
philosophic framework okay a physicist
told them
told uh mr vogt
that he had discovered the philosophy
that string theories string theorists
have been looking for the theory does
much more
it unites parts of quantum mechanics
with parts of strength theory
now you see where he's going with all
this it does it by first assuming that
the theory
uh first it does it by first assuming
that the
universe is the product of information
and the information forms the matter
world we live in
okay so you can see how this guy is uh
this poor chap is going in that
direction okay
and uh so here we have number four it
says the purpose of the foundation's
research is to see if global warming
now where did he get that global warming
i guess from the news
because it's on the news every day for
the last 50 years so people are talking
a lot about that
and so he's very concerned about that
global warming global warming is
probably going to cause the extinction
of man
especially if the sun novas or whatever
right so he's going to put all these
together
global warming is caused by collapsing
magnetic field on the earth
and the sun which will eventually
culminate in a
geomagnetic reversal then
an ice age on the earth okay
okay so uh he's uh he's gonna argue
that uh we're gonna have a reversal of
the poles uh
polar reversal it's gonna be caused by
something happening to our
the magnetic field of the earth that in
turn is going to be caused by something
happening in the sun
apparently some super nova or nova or
mini nova micro
or whatever uh okay and so he wants once
to prepare for that because he's
calculated it's going to happen in the
year 2046.
so if you live that long hopefully i
don't
i'm too old to live i think to 2046. i
think i'm going to die
much sooner than that one way or the
other right either by natural causes
or because we go into extinction
and so where does he get all this stuff
let's see he did some research maybe or
he got some funds for
i don't know some deep thinking or
something
well no he gets it from a book the uh
the pentatonic uh the uh
jewish book uh known as the torah
torah has like two definitions one is
the first five books supposedly written
by moses
where moses you know tells us that he
died
they call him the first my book of moses
moses dies
in one of those books okay uh that's one
the other one is that it extends all the
way to chronicles
which is when the jews were deported by
uh to babylonia okay
or around the time of cyrus the great
maybe 550
bc or so okay you may wonder why
science foundation yeah science
foundation okay
whose goals are to study the causes of
the ice ages
polar reversals and develop an
information
theory of existence would get involved
in studying the torah
bible old testament yeah why would they
i mean
[Laughter]
the reasons are what the founder that
man there okay
discovered about the hebrew alphabet
okay that the exact number of years
between geomagnetic reversals were
embedded as code in the surface story of
the
torah aha so we have some secret
information these
these uh holy books may be given to us
by
god for the chosen people who knows i
mean let's find out
the second discovery was that the hebrew
alphabet
and the torah is the product of a very
highly advanced
previous civilization that had the same
information
theory of existence as the one we are
developing
the theory of multi-dimensional reality
so he rediscovered the multi-dimensional
theory of reality
and he got it from i guess from the
torah he was able to read all these
secret codes and messages that were
embedded in there and
that nobody else could and so he re
uh hashed this old theory that
we stupid humans lost over the centuries
time erased it okay
um here is uh
he reinforces that saying the reason why
the book includes both
religious as well as hard science
subjects
is because of what the author had
discovered the author is uh
mr vogt there chap okay
one of his most proud discoveries is to
discover the model that created the
original
22 hebrew letters whoa normally you
would not think
this would be a major scientific
discovery but it was
the original hebrew alphabet is 22 views
of a wave form that is a modified
square wave you see it there on the
right i guess uh the egyptians had a
good old horus you know touching his
fingers there
alpha's views of a waveform that is
modified square wave
superimposed on a toroid this
model of a toroid is a model of how the
carbon atom comes
into existence as three-dimensional
matter
remember he's talking about matter he's
talking about uh
three-dimensionality okay so he's
talking about i guess things that exist
okay every single letter is formed when
the waveform crosses the x-axis
okay there you see uh the waveform i
probably screwed up i should have made
it across the axis okay but
okay minor detail uh he can beat me up
for that one
no problem and uh so here it is the
toroidal
okay uh this is his view of it uh
i made my own drawing of it okay
it says the toroid shape represents how
carbon atom comes into this dimension
okay that thingy there i don't know how
that
has anything to do with anything but
okay he's got this waveform again he
doesn't specify
what the wave is made out of you know
what what is the physical
object that underlies the wave that's
what we would like to see like if you
propose
transverse wave we say well what is
waving and you would have to say
well particles are waving well what kind
of particles
like classical corpuscles no they're
amounts
they have location no it's a
probabilistic
theory and that's how they fool you
around with all this
word wizardry okay
so let's continue here and so we still
have the
scrolls there the taurus
whoa shows that the torah is actually
some kind of computer program
computer program where could he get that
computer program maybe from
this day and age i mean you know i
worked in the industry for many years
and uh we did chips and so
uh you know this started really growing
quite fast after
about 1980 uh the chip really developed
very fast after that
right even a little before that but 1980
i entered
the industry in 1979 so uh
i was quite familiar with with the whole
trend worked there for many years and uh
says
uh kind of computer program used to
program a light
based computer whoa okay the publication
of this book marks the first time
anyone has scientifically proven the
existence of god
now how's that for
proof for evidence here this man says
he's
proven the existence of god all these
years
atheists and theists and agnostics
they're
fighting over nothing they should have
gone to this man i mean he's already
proven the existence of god
okay and his relation his the good old
man upstairs the bearded guy okay
uh his relationship to the universe the
author provides the groundwork to prove
proof science is proof or
religion is proof yeah in religion we
prove we try to convert
we try to persuade in order to
recruit people okay that's what the
pastor does on sunday you know sunday
school
to prove that there is some kind of
intelligent design
now where did i read that i'm sure i've
heard that before
uh fundamentalist churches design
okay design process working in the
universe
okay there's some mysterious designer
out there okay
for any theory of existence to be
correct correct
correct that's not correct is religion
opinion what's correct to you is
incorrect to your neighbor
right what's true to you false to your
neighbor what's yes to you no to your
neighbor and so on
yeah they they use these words correct
proof
evidence data
all these people are doing the
mathematical mathematical
method not the scientific method they
harp on
persuasion on conversion on recruiting
on converting you know for any theory of
existence to be correct it must be able
to answer the three most
difficult questions in the universe oh
three most difficult questions in the
unit talking physics here
right why was the universe created
created
someone created the universe i thought
it was always around
how can you create something from
nothing
from or worse like he says from a
concept from information
uh of course uh good old stephen hawking
he does it from energy
so you can't blame the guy this guy does
it with energy
this uh chap here he does it with
information another concept if god
created the universe okay
so it's not a not a guaranteed thing
it's an if okay
then who created god good question
okay and uh yeah you can wait all year
to
figure out who created god because then
you gotta figure out who created the who
who created god
so who was god's mother you know who
created his mother and
her mother and her mother and so on down
the line and what is man's purpose in
the universe
his purpose is to become
now extinct settles that okay that's the
purpose of man
he's gonna become extinct and that'll be
the end of man
we won't have to listen to any more of
this nonsense if we become extinct
so sometimes i pray for extinction other
times you know i'd like to live a little
longer
my kids my grandsons but i don't think
it's gonna happen
okay uh so um here's god uh
with his computer okay so if you ever
wanna see i
saw him the other day i went there and
took a picture so hi god how you doing
um yeah that's god running his computer
he's the guy
who runs this universe uh information
comes out of that big box there
of course uh this computer's
super computer it handles every one of
your thoughts every person that's living
on earth
and that has lived on earth we go with a
blocked universe it's
every person since day one and even
all the way to cambrian i guess right
all the animals he governs everything
that computer there there there you have
the block universe in there
we'll call it the block computer
okay um
uh mr
vog chap has uh closing arguments
where he kind of summarizes he says why
is the earth getting warmer
because that's his his main pet peeve he
he says in the year 2046 that's it for
all of us
or for most of us unless government does
something now right we got to influence
government from now on
scientists do not know why all ice ages
are preceded with a
geomagnetic polar reversal
okay we know there was a great mass
extinction of species following the
polar reversal in
ice age but we don't understand why the
extinctions affect both plants and
animals worldwide
the problem is the matter-oriented
theory of existence
it's all these materialists like bill
gatey you know they're confusing people
forget about matter we do physics
without matter
our science is based on a
matter-oriented theory of existence
which assumes that matter is the
dominant
driving force in the universe well i
don't know about driving force uh
i'm not sure you can do anything without
matter
i mean again like i started my talk uh
if there's nothing in the universe
there's no matter no atoms
what's happening what's going on are we
moving concepts around
energy in that direction information the
other direction we lift the mass we
blower the charge
we stretch the time
compress the field are we going to do it
with concepts
concepts are invented by man mother
nature recognizes no concepts he only
understands objects okay this fellow
says that forget about matter
the only other alternative to explain
the workings of the universe is an
information
theory of existence you gotta
go back to information why because we're
in the age of
this information this is part of the
disinformation
this philosophy holds that
disinformation i'm sorry
information is the dominant force in the
universe and the matter world we live in
is the product of information the
information derives from another
time space space-time dimension
forget about the einstein's ridiculous
four-dimensional universe this uh
proposes a few more
i think he proposes up to eight
dimensions
and yeah you can look him up and you'll
find
he's got a book or a synopsis of his
book out there you can
read okay uh
some people might say
uh oh no first
let me go with this first you know he
he's putting his money where his mouth
is
that's important to understand he's
proposing
not a challenge he's pulling a uh
proposing a
challenge a challange okay
and this is the challenge okay that he's
got
on his website and he's offering money
putting his money where his mouth is he
said hey you know i'm offering money now
i don't know if you can read that let me
put
a bigger and more
concise version of what he's got there
that's your 1200 buck
challenge or challange i'm sorry
the challenge is to anyone who can prove
the author wrong
i love this about what causes the ice
agent polar reversal
geomagnetic reverse on why they occur at
the same time namely the geomagnetic
reversal
happens first at the same time are sun
novas
the challenger must have proof of
purchase of my book
okay you must also come up with a
unified theory of existence that
explains
all the scientific phenomena listed on
the science page
if you cannot do that you have nothing
the existing matter-oriented theory of
existence is wrong
and only an information theory of
existence can explain it
the author is confident no one can
succeed because over a hundred thousand
scientists
over the past hundred years have tried
to come up with a theory that explains
everything
and have failed miserably the reason is
so obvious the foundation philosophy of
science is at fault well there i agree
but he he's got the same foundation
which is mathematical
uh the mathematical method namely that
matter is not the dominant force in the
universe
information is no the fault is that he's
following the wrong scientific method he
thinks
science is about persuading convincing
and offering
money for a child for someone to you
know challenge
so that someone can prove them wrong and
who's going to judge that well it's
going to be his organization okay
the reason is so obvious is oh sorry if
the challenger is unable to prove an
alternative theory within three months
he or she will make a 500 contribution
to the die hold foundation
[Laughter]
now how's that for uh for a challenge
okay
i love this guy made me laugh now uh
some people might say bill why do you
bother with these people so here's
here's here's my challange
okay uh let me tell you why why i have
to why
bother with these poor souls okay first
they
they clogged the internet okay and so uh
you know the question is whether they're
allowed to speak they should be allowed
to speak
well everybody's got a right to speak
and put anything they want on the
internet but what that causes is
a lot of traffic and everyone
ends up you know who wants to challenge
the uh the
charlotte i'm sorry once a challange the
establishment uh becomes a needle in the
haystack
and i'm one of those you know i'm just a
little needle in the haystack
i don't pride myself in having lots of
followers it's not important to me
what's important is that the few people
who discover me by chance
well at least they get another vision of
how this universe works
and also what arguments to lift against
the
uh unscientific establishment including
this gentleman here uh
second because they mislead the public
people like him just mislead the public
some people fall and they think that
this guy is a scientist
i mean if he wants to do
something else like religion there's a
place and a time for that
you know some people might say well bill
what's the harm i mean
uh the guy um proposes
something that uh is different
and it uh stimulates our minds right we
have more
ideas out there well you know there's a
time and a place for that
like if he's going to do entertainment
or he's going to do religion
you know he he i mean he wants to be a
stand-up comedian fine go and do
comedy but don't you know
uh do false advertising and present this
as
science you know there's a time and a
place for that
and that comes a little bit with my
parable of the martian some of you know
that
parable and i'll just regurgitate it for
those who don't
okay the martians decide to send their
number one commander to earth
okay and he give him instructions
bring the most intelligent speed uh
animal you can find down there the most
intelligent uh being that you can find
there
okay so commander comes down and he
lands with this flying saucer he lands
in a
cemetery early in the morning about six
o'clock in the morning
and here's this lady come in with her
dog and the dog is not on a leash
because
you know they're very early there's
nobody there the dog
runs up ahead he already knows where to
go he knows the
tomb by by heart so he goes there
you know he uh goes to the tomb lifts
his right leg takes a whiz
right and he with his hind legs he kind
of throws a little bit of dirt in there
just keeps running around
the uh cemetery for a little while
chasing rabbits maybe
and uh the lady comes in the little lady
with a bouquet of flowers
puts the flowers in there changes them
in this vase
and uh she kneels she prays
and then she kisses the tombstone right
where the dog
did his thing well
yeah martian didn't think it twice he
took the dog back to mars
okay and uh and so
this this is more or less like brings my
memory
uh let's fall prometheus you know he was
uh one of these
uh gods of the greeks
and he came out and he gave fire to man
but this time now we're gonna modify it
a little bit prometheus
comes and gives not fire fires
petty stuff he gives intelligence to man
he lets man eat from the tree of
knowledge
okay and so what happens
you know who's gets this guy ties him up
against the
mountain who's gonna have this eagle
start eating his liver you know forever
for
this crime that he's committed giving
intelligence to man
and prometheus says no no no no zeus you
get it all wrong you
you misunderstood okay prommy
speak up you got 10 seconds to make your
case
so prometheus says look i gave
intelligence to man
so that we could have the laugh or of
our lifetimes
what do you mean he says look
we gave intelligence to man and what did
they come up with they came up with big
bang
with space time warp space time they
came up with black holes dark
matter they came up with particles being
at two places at wands
they came up with so much nonsense
and it turns out that ants
which don't have the intelligence of man
starfish
even a bag of potatoes has more
intelligence than man
that i gave intelligence to
and that's more or less what this chap
uh vote is in you know here um
they gave him intelligence or reasoning
abilities you could say
and he squandered this gift
he squandered it completely he comes up
with so much
nonsense that's just unbelievable
and of course the the gods out there are
laughing
their heads up because see if he was
doing stand-up comedy
then it wouldn't be so funny and i said
okay he's joking
but it turns out this guy is serious and
he really believes in this nonsense so
the
gods are having a ball they're busting
their guts with this guy
and uh that's more or less where i can
put uh mr
uh vote okay i don't think uh
i don't think you know it's it's a it's
uh it tells us a lot about today
about what we see out there what we hear
out there we have all these deranged
um deluded individuals
who post stuff on on the internet and
again
what they do is they crowd out you know
the needle in the haystacks he turns
everybody into a needle in a haystack
because there's so many people doing
this nonsense
of you know from the establishment also
so-called dissidents
so yeah mr vogt belongs to the dissident
branch
so that is in a nutshell uh what mr vote
is about you can look up
i guess his book and his stuff on the
internet easy to find
have fun with it i hope you laugh as
much as the gods are laughing